well since history has finally been
outlawed by the American left we're here
to remind you that Robert Muller is not
the first special counsel to dominate
American political life it was 20 years
ago this fall right now that impeachment
proceedings began against then President
Bill Clinton they were based on the
findings of Kenneth Starr special
investigation into Bill Clinton for 20
years Starr has avoided revealing his
full thoughts about what happened but
now he is he has a new book out it is
called contempt a memoir of the Clinton
investigation Ken Starr joins us tonight
we really glad to have you thank you
very much for coming on hey Thank You
Chuck it's good to be with you so you of
course ran a special counsel
investigation you're watching one now in
progress have your views on the
existence of a special counsel changed
and are you impressed by what mr. Muller
appears to be doing well my views have
not changed that well there is a need
for this mechanism my views have not
changed that there was and I recount
this in the book in some detail the
Independent Counsel statute Tucker I
think was the wrong way to go but we do
want honesty in government that in
theory is what this is all about I do
applaud Bob Muller for bringing the
indictments against the Russian
individuals and organizations those are
very powerful indictments and I think
they're getting to the heart of what
happened now almost two years ago but I
also say this those indictments do not
read about collusion they read about
unilateral action by Russian operatives
to try to affect our election I have
serious doubt that there was an effect
we're a big country we are a country
with it's a very vibrant robust
democracy and so I write in reading and
reading some of the ads I thought they
were sort of pathetic and stupid they
were pathetic and stupid so you you
write that one of the reasons we have a
special counsel statute is to reassure
the public that our institutions are on
the level so I mean that's that's part
of the function is to make people
realize you know make them believe that
justice is impartial and in fact deliver
impartial justice with that in mind are
you come from the fact that Muller seems
to have hired exclusively partisan
Democrat
takes to know their affiliation no I'm
not
Tucker I have great confidence in Bob
Muller as a person so I'm in the school
that Bob Muller is a good and decent man
Semper Fi
but I must say and in the book I try to
make the point and I do make the point
that when there are these kinds of
charges or concerns about partisanship
the special counsel needs to respond to
those and so I tell the story of why it
is that we built-in guardrails to make
sure that there could be no fair and
objective attack that the investigation
was partisan of course the attacks came
but the attacks were very ill founded
and and I think that was part of what
Bob Muller was obligated to do so I do
have concerns about the people around
him yeah well I think those are those
were well-placed two quick things about
your book first you say that you came
close to charging Hillary with perjury
she said I don't know where I can't
recall dozens and dozens of times in
your interview clearly she was like why
didn't you charge her you have to be
able to prove the case as I make clear
in the book there are clear differences
Tucker between what a prosecutor knows
and what the prosecutor can prove so we
were following Justice Department policy
we knew we had to prove the case each
element the case beyond a reasonable
doubt and we came to the view after
looking at a very elaborate draft
indictment a supportive prosecution memo
that as I described in the book we
decided we just did not have the
evidence to to bring those charges and
and quickly this just jumped out at me
you said you were haunted by the Vince
Foster cases his his death in Washington
or the early part of the Clinton's first
term why because as I described in the
book we were trying to get to the bottom
of among other things how Hillary
Clinton's billing records at the Raw's
law firm mysteriously disappeared which
was theft from the rose law firm and
then mysteriously reappeared in the book
room where Hillary was writing a book
now how did that happen how did records
in those pre electronic records
when their way not just out of the law
firm offices in Little Rock Arkansas but
to the private residence of the
president and the first lady and my I
was haunted by what did Vince Foster do
as the deputy counsel to the president
he took his own life we knew that he was
depressed we had very significant
evidence that he was clinically
depressed
why was he clinically depressed complex
question but that's why I was haunted
why did this very successful very bright
lawyer take his own life within six
months of the administration taking
power and that haunts me to this day
yeah well you're not the only one for
sure Ken Stark great to see you after
all these many years think hey thanks
Tucker